we got Sada baby in the building we got
Skillet baby in the building it's a
Detroit situation in here and decided
right before we went live he was like yo
cab make sure all the fans know when I
do these clubs they got to come up and
touch my beard I like it a lot
definitely
no but you got you can't just touch it
you gotta rub your fingers you gotta
pull it
so how long
[Music]
get up quick
y'all get somebody beat the up you
hate people touching your beard I don't
like people touching my face
just your face
I feel like women is that the first
thing women reach for though is the
beard
um
we'll be like like probably like one out
of five a dinner like off the dribble
trying to touch my baby you have to be
like yo I just grabbed a hand I just
grabbed it here what if I just grabbed
your cheek right now
would you like that
[Laughter]
you ain't gonna say five is a lot of
women five one out of five yeah
I'm saying I'm saying like if we taking
pictures or something like I'm doing
meet and greet or like that that's wild
like like one like probably one out of
85 but damn they're just like oh my God
you've hit me and just try to touch my
beard no that's crazy nah it has been
like a couple instances to where it
didn't just super duper irritate might
just be like God down but
I wanted to tell them that I always hate
on them yeah it is glorious it's good
man being a pretty fire but much better
you don't have a you got a better
mustache than me
baby
non-existent mustache nice dare from
went from when he used to didn't it used
to didn't be there at all hey you know I
mean little baby girl facial hair like
my teenage son bro I was your teenage I
was your son 17.
so you saying my beer don't look better
than that
what is this this is stubble that's not
a beard that's that's more than stubborn
stubble is crazy a little goat it's a
goat tea okay so a goatee is not a beard
it's a little one has a beard a little
goat little goatee you don't get what
I'm doing Juan got the best mustache at
the table
cap
what
have you had anyone think you were
Muslim because of your beard
no no I caught it uh they call it as a
Dominican today
that's tight I mean shout out to the Dr
is a good place to visit everybody no I
want to be telling me we're supposed to
go they have this drink in the Dr called
Mama Juana with the wood with the wood
in it bro and that every every Resort
they're like they call it Dominican
Powers respect Viagra yeah supposed to
get you a horny just help me at work
have you had it I don't do performance
enhancers how have we already discussed
this before you're not the honey pack
guy not my nickname what is your
nickname perk you off the perk huh
um
that's an enhancer I'm the perk oh you
are the perk
hmm
yeah I know you do yeah and and Rhino
gas station pills honey packs I have
that I've done honey back but I don't do
honey pigs dog right here though
who who won right here one you do a
honey pack no he go to the field
Pharmacy hey have you ever had a
Bluetooth
that's on the YouTube commercials
somebody give me that that's actually
called the Bluetooth no you anything I
got the drink oh it's a yeah no drink no
you got blue juice yeah yeah it's a uh
listen if you go to bluetooth.com and
you and you use the promo code bootleg
right now you'll save oh you promote a
whole entire free month to give you a
month for free blueshoe.com what are we
talking about yeah my boy top my boy
Tata Glover man bought his life Uber
here Bluetooth uh sponsor too yeah well
listen have you guys ever had a generic
Viagra no like I never had viagras yeah
they told me that that you start seeing
green and red oh viagras yes I'm scared
of that boy
I ain't scared of it I'm not scared
well the thing is is like if you're
drinking or you're on certain substances
right you know it's been like that since
I was 16. they get drunk and y'all turn
it up if you hear me you can uh you know
take care of the shortcomings I should
never got I should have never got a
drink when I was 16 and if you hit me
ever since then I'm like well it's gonna
make it turned up like that
you feel me I tried honey pass before I
don't like them you know what I'm saying
but enough liquor you know you kill me
yeah you tell my Bluetooth
I ain't got no Bluetooth I call it
everything Bluetooth though because I
know what that is